pues sin traduce algunas modificaciones
a la ley actual vigente del aborto de
2010 como mencionabas que permite en la
interrupción del embarazo hasta la
semana 14 de manera libre y hasta la
semana 21 por razones médicas que son
estas novedades pues vuelve a introducir
la posibilidad de que las menores de 16
y 17 años y que las mujeres con
discapacidad puedan abortar libremente
sin tener que pedir permiso a sus padres
oa sus tutores además se eliminan las 72
horas o los 3 días de reflexión que
existían hasta ahora para poder
practicarse una interrupción del
embarazo y según la ministra de igualdad
irene montero es porque el estado no
duda de la decisión que tomen las
mujeres se introduce también una baja
por incapacidad después de hacer de
performance hacerse o de practicarse un
aborto y se creará un registro de
objetores de conciencia para que pues
para facilitar que estas prácticas se
puedan llevar a cabo en la sanidad
pública puesto que en españa a pesar de
ser legal
tantos objetores de conciencia en la
sanidad pública que el 85 por ciento de
los abortos se realiza en clínicas
acreditadas pero de la sanidad privada
claro marina pero además hay puntos
importantes sobre la salud reproductiva
que contiene finalmente este
anteproyecto
y es que lo que quiere la ministra de
igualdad y el resto de ministerios
involucrados en crear este anteproyecto
de ley es que la salud menstrual sea un
derecho más de las mujeres y por eso y
por primera vez en europa incluyen bajas
laborales por incapacidad
porque tengas reglas o menstruaciones
dolorosas no habría un límite de días a
esa baja laboral pero sí tendría que
venir con un diagnóstico médico también
cataloga como violencia hacia las
mujeres las
los embarazos o las gestaciones
subrogadas o vientres de alquiler una
práctica que en españa está prohibida
pero que muchas parejas españolas van al
extranjero a hacerlas y lo que harían no
es prohibir las porque ya están
prohibidas dentro de españa pero
prohibirían la publicidad de este tipo
de prácticas en el extranjero es una
práctica que ha suscitado mucha polémica
puesto que los defensores de la decisión
de la mujer del cuerpo de la mujer dicen
que si la mujer es libre de decidir
sobre su propio cuerpo también lo podría
hacer si quiere convertirse en un
vientre de alquiler así que es un tiempo
una medida que ha suscitado bastante
polémica y finalmente quedó fuera de
este anteproyecto de ley la rebaja del
iva del 10% al 4% de los productos de
higiene femenina como tampones compresas
o la copa menstrual pero pretenden
incluirla dentro de los próximos
presupuestos generales del estado aún
falta bastante tiempo para que este
anteproyecto pueda convertirse en ley no
se estima que pueda ser posible antes de
2023 porque tiene que pasar por todo el
proceso legislativo para que sea
aprobado en las cortes